so it's like as we've industrialized
many of many people have had issues with
working inside of factories and having
exposure to certain classes of chemicals
but then also there's just on a mass
population scale those that have
progressed to let's say just advancing
the countries into whatever first world
countries that they're exposed to BPA
and other forms of exposure to and your
endocrine implication system implication
that then cost things like infertility
this is all very interesting because
there's so many downstream effects that
it's hard to measure longitudinally over
like 50 years what it what it does I
mean we were just talking about this
earlier this episode just people being
jammed into little boxes on top of each
other in Metropolis is well when you
don't get that much natural light when
you're not getting that much exposure to
fresh air when you're not getting that
much exercise or you're not getting
enough sleep because there's just
economic machinery pressuring you all
the time you're far away from your
family you're far away from raising
children all this type of stuff there's
many downstream implications that happen
including the onset of cancer and
cardiovascular disease and Alzheimer's
and all these other things that are very
difficult to men to measure this the
intricacy of the nuanced multi
variability yet it's quite
physiologically evident on a
moment-to-moment basis you know when you
actually feel like you're divinely at
your peak state of performance versus
feels like meat inhaling the cars
exhaust on the street in a breath of air
feels like it actually sheds minutes off
of downstream my life versus indigeneity
people that are still living in complete
symbiosis with nature
they have just
a much more cohesive understanding of
the interconnectedness of everything
plus their like their environmental
anthropological awareness level must be
like a 90 on a scale of zero to a
hundred and ours and metropolis feels
like it's 20 or 30 it's disastrous it
feels disastrous